you're welcome to this video I'm playing
our thoughts a thurs probably just
artists with sir estonia and you're one
of the Baltic countries oh this is weird
what the heck just happened there okay
we got a king's indian and let's see I
could I could try this line i don't
think i ever played it on video it's
quite interesting you should be 392 this
has been played down very often my
American Grandmaster yes a ceremony with
them lots of success actually it's um
it's very often leading to positions
that are very similar to the sameish
variation I'm thinking about f3 here
yeah maybe you might not he could play
night h5 I thought you should play night
h5 really ok let's continue Queen d2 is
the next news bishops to of course also
possible yeah I don't mind this age 6
seems to me like a weakness Queen d2 our
attack aged 6 and gained a temple on
night c5 you always play Bishop c2 yeah
okay yeah I could he could play on Queen
d2 we could actually ignore this thread
on edge tix because of the screen h4
check I like f5 Bishop takes Queen age
for check and I'm losing the piece but
it's it's not a big problem anyway okay
what now many interesting moves
one possible movers even gphone
immediately okay but let's castle first
I can always play g4 did I say g3 g4 of
course g4s the idea I need to get rid of
this a five-pound even as a pawn sec
this would open up the bishop on d3 and
it if he takes on g4 it just opens up
the g file against the king and
something like g4 f-4s of course
excellent for four wide hmm yeah this is
curious what is he doing over them g3
where do you go interesting ok I'll do
that first and work out the details
later
g3 is not a not a bad move anyway the
question is should i have play G for now
takes 93 gaining this temple looks very
nice Queen moves but it's not it's not
direct window anything still I wonder if
if I could maybe just prepare all this
like h3g for isn't this very convenient
way to to beget he simply he has no real
way to prevent that I can't even play
that that move first and then h3g for I
know it's a bit slow but what what what
should he do against it I don't see it
and once I play g5 it's basically over
the position opens up and I have all
pieces on the king bishop to h6 Bishop
see 22 h 7 and the lions gate opened for
the rooks maybe I had some more
energetic way to play with a pollen sack
but this is just the keep everything
under control method okay yeah just take
him is there something better even you
should f 2 mm it's not not that great
can also play a phone also not bad at
all okay let's do this takes Knight
takes a disaster and if he takes on g4 I
recapture and the H file opens up so we
cannot take any of the pawns and if you
place F everybody for I have an ID for a
bishop d for both are very good amongst
others but getting this square is very
nice I think I go 90 for increasing
pressure on their five and still if it
takes on g4 a to take G for Queen takes
f5 it's going to explode on h6 yeah I'm
just rattling to take a five now and if
f 5 volts then the rest crumbles you
fall in particular
and I don't know maybe you had some
energy more energetic wait to play but
this looks are quite convincing I'm
taking with the pawn because I want to
play 96 right now or should I take e for
first and he's got 93 it's got night g3
coming ok ok if you bless nigeria i'm
just going to sack the exchange
I don't think girl black can survive
this or maybe on night g3 I can just
play a [ __ ] h2 at that book g do not bad
yeah an IG 3i can also play Queen f2 for
starters ok he just took a five
amazingly yeah okay let's let's take it
if it's not that easy actually at least
I didn't see a clear-cut winner
I still have this glossy cord
yeah how am I going to win I mean it
looks very very nice but it's down a
direct win I can I can take you for all
the time that I may be here I should
have the look of the Rock has no square
after Bishop f6 the ruckus trapped he
takes on c3 md i'm capturing with check
maybe this is still the best way for him
to play but shouldn't shouldn't be
enough William yang and what now the
sugar is hanging on Bishop g6 maybe
Bishop g6 attacking my light where is it
going can only return now return here g6
g6 threatening look aged six mate yeah
yeah almost made Queen age seven I can
apply but he didn't have lines look F
ather there was no defense anymore and
this was really really bad out of the
opening in fact I think he should he
shouldn't play a five year I also
haven't canceled yet so this is really
important if I would have canceled short
already then you can make me maybe go at
five but in this particular scenario
long castles is just just very strong
because that's going to happen reform
and this is really helped me a lot we
have this very suspicious i'm playing
all the computer moves but it's just
just
simple and good year a g3 and g4 I'm
checking with the combat wants to play
all those moves it's quite quite funny
and even now even f4 I'd wants to play
okay okay now the computer wants to play
kingdom on i'm glad that i didn't didn't
play that as well played 94 per game and
this is very nice oh oh I missed I
missed Bishop f2 that's funny it took me
a couple of seconds to capture on air
five so I'm not a comp but this just
kept us up traps the Queen I completely
forgot about that idea we came I took
the pawn I mean it keeps this big
advantage but it would have been much
easier of course no I still this was
quite okay this is even stronger I'm
sorry I hope you still have your ears
intact yeah and at the end yeah there
was this made coming alright thanks for
watching